الحرب في اوكرانيا وضعت الجيش الامريكي
تحت ضغوط كبيره من جهه يحاول تامين كل ما
تحتاجه اوكرانيا من مساعدات عسكريه ومن
جهه اخرى يحاول الحفاظ على تفوقه العسكري
الحفاظ على التفوق العسكري الامريكي واحد
من اكثر المسائل الملحه دائما
لكنه الان يكتسب اهميه خاصه في ظل تنامي
القدرات العسكريه الصينيه وكذلك ما تقوم
به بكين من تحديث مستمر لترسانتها
العسكريه لكن الى اي مدى الولايات المتحده
قادره على الحفاظ على تفوقها العسكري خلال
السنوات القادمه خاصه في ظل ما تقوم به من
ارسال لاسلحه الى الاوكرانيين في الوقت
الحالي هذا ما سنناقشه مع السيده اندرو
ماتريك الباحث في برنامج الدراسات
والدفاعيه في مركز امن امريكا الجديده
اولا السيد اندرو يعني علم الى اي مدى
برايك اثرت الحرب في اوكرانيا على
استراتيجيه التسلح الخاصه بالجيش الامريكي
في هذه المرحله
شكرا جزيلا لاستضافه اعتقد ان الحرب في
اوكرانيا وباشكال عديده برهنت على صحه
العديد من افكار الولايات المتحده
الاساسيه في الشؤون الامنيه واستراتيجيتها
العسكريه للعشرين او الثلاثين عاما
الماضيه وهنا تكمن قيمه الاصدقاء والشركاء
والعمل من خلال الدول التي لديها توجهات
متشابهه وفي مثالنا الحالي تعمل الولايات
المتحده وحلفائها في النيتو عن قرب مع
الاوكرانيين لمقاومه الاعتداء الروسي
واعتقد ان هذه المقاربه اكدت الكثير من
الاشياء التي تحدثت عنها الاداره
الامريكيه لكن سيد اندرو فيما يتعلق بنقاط
الضعف التي اكتشفتها واشنطن في برامج
التسلح الخاصه بها برايك ما هي اكثر نقاط
الضعف لفتت انتباه البنتاجون في هذه
المرحله
اعتقد ان اهم ما يركز عليه البنتون حاليا
في الحوارات اليوميه هو القاعده الصناعيه
الدفاعيه وصناعه الدفاع وقدرتها على انتاج
وصناعه تشكيله واسعه من القدرات المختلفه
من الدبابات والمدفعيه وصولا الى الطائرات
والقنابل فالاداره والبنتاجون قلقان بسبب
تركيز صناعه الدفاع الامريكيه على الكفاءه
وتحسين القيمه التي يحصل عليها كل دافع
ضرائب مقابل اموال الضرائب التي يدفعها
الا ان ما شاهدناه في اوكرانيا اثبت ان
خوض الحروب المفاجئه والعنيفه يستهلك
كميات كبيره من المواد ووزاره الدفاع تشعر
بان الصناعه الامريكيه ليست لديها القدره
على الانتاج بالنطاق الذي ترغب به الوزاره
في المستقبل
السيد اندرو دائما لا يتوقف العسكريون في
واشنطن عن المطالبه بزياده الميزانيه
العسكريه لكن برايك هذا الامر من قبيل
التمويه انه هناك بالفعل احتياجات للجيش
الامريكي لا تلبيها الاداره
اعتقد ان الجواب عن هذا السؤال هو للاسف
نعم واعتقد ان الجواب يحتمل الاثنين فمن
جهه هناك تنافس مستمر على الموارد بين
الدوائر العسكريه المختلفه هنا في واشنطن
وجزء من ذلك يعود للرغبه في زياده الموارد
والجزء الاخر يعود لاحساس المسؤولين وبشكل
ملح بان امريكا تواجه تحديا يتمثل في
الصين وهو تحدى لم يواجهه المسؤولين بهذا
الحجم منذ نهايه الحرب البارده وهذا ما
دفع العاملين في سياسه امريكا الخارجيه
لتغيير افكارهم الخاصه بالمسائل الدفاعيه
من ناحيه واثر ذلك ايضا على توفير الموارد
فنعم هناك عنصر خاص بالالاعيب
البيروقراطيه وعنصر اخر خاص بجمع الموارد
السيد اندرو يعني خفيا بانه الصين او
الصين الان والتفوق العسكري الصيني في هذه
المرحله من الامور المطلقه جدا لوشنطن اذا
استمرت الصين على هذه الوتيره من التصنيع
العسكري هل سنجد يوما ما تفوق عسكري صيني
على الولايات المتحده
من الصعب جدا الاجابه عن هذا السؤال من
الاشياء التي يجب ان نتذكرها هي ان كل
تنافس عسكريا حدث على مر التاريخ كان له
تاثير تفاعلي فمثلا الصين تتخذ خطوه من
هذا الجانب وامريكا ترد من الجانب الاخر
في بعض المناطق اعتقد ان على امريكا
التعود على التحركات العسكريه الصينيه
العدائيه بسبب العوامل الجغرافيه في
المناطق التي تتنافس عليها الدولتان خاصه
تايوان اما شكل ذلك بعد عشره اعوام او حتى
20 او 39 عاما من الان فمن الصعب جدا
تحديده ولكن بعد كل ما سمع من واشنطن
فهناك قلق متنام حول هذا الامر اما كيف
سيتعامل البلدان فيما بينهما في المستقبل
فكل ذلك سيعتمد على الجانب السياسي
الدينميكيات العسكريه ستفرض بعض الشروط
الا ان الامر يعتمد على القياده السياسيه
واسلوب ادارتها للمواجهه بين البلدين
مستقبلا وهي التي ستقرر في الختام كيفيه
تحقيق التوازن العسكري السيد اندرو لا شك
بانه الشركات الامريكيه استفادت كثيرا
خاصه من الدول التي كانت لديها اسلحه
سوفيتيه وتستبدلها الان باسلحه امريكيه
لكن الى اي مدى الشركات الامريكيه العامله
في مجال الصناعات الدفاعيه قادره على
تلبيه هذا الكم الكبير من الطلبات
هذا سؤال وجيه باشكال عديده اعتقد انهم
متحمسون لتلبيه متطلبات وزاره الدفاع
لزياده الانتاج وتحديث القدرات الدفاعيه
لكن السؤال الاساسي
وهل الولايات المتحده بحاجه الى مراجعه
سياساتها التصديريه المتعلقه بالاسلحه
والانظمه الدفاعيه بشكل كامل حول العالم
حتى لا تخسر شركائها او حلفائها
اعتقد ان هذه واحده من التحديات الموروثه
من مقاربه امريكا القائمه على القيم لدينا
قيم نعتز بها ونريد ان نتاكد من بيعنا
للاسلحه لدول اخرى لا تستخدمها بشكل لا
ندعمه او ان تكون تلك الدول غير متوافقه
ما قيمنا وبسبب ذلك لدينا نظام صارم
للتحقق قبل تصدير الاسلحه وبصراحه هذا
يضعنا في موقف ضعف مقارنه بالصينيين الذين
لا يفعلون ذلك لكن في الختام اعتقد ان
عمليه اتخاذ هذه القرارات يمكن ان يتم
تحسينها لتكون اكثر كفاءه وكما اجبت عن
العديد من الاسئله الامر في الختام يعتمد
على هويه امريكا كدوله كيف تحب ان تظهر
هناك حالات يمكن لامريكا ان تخفف
اجراءاتها في تصدير الاسلحه وفي حالات
اخرى اثبتت ضوابط صادرات امريكا الدفاعيه
انها صحيحه كما انهم يقومون بعمل حيوي وهو
المحافظه على القاعده الصناعيه الدفاعيه
الخاصه بامريكا من الصعب جدا تحقيق
التوازن في هذه المعادله ولا شك ان هناك
مجال للاصلاح ولكن في نفس الوقت هناك
اسباب تدفعها للاستمرار في عملها كما هو
عليه اليوم